how y'all doing i-i've lived in Los
Angeles for about three years and I'm
originally from a small town in
Tennessee and when I tell people that in
Los Angeles it confuses them they're
always like oh like Chattanooga I'm like
no what no oh you have no idea do you
okay
how can I explain okay when I was in
fifth grade my older cousin went to a
field party got in a fight and killed a
dude when I was in high school the dead
dude sister asked me to the prom that's
a small town he gets not a lot of
options
I had to decline her offer because my
father made a solid point when he went
know about that she might have forgot
but I don't think her daddy did people
in the South love that joke so much it
makes people outside the south sad
people in the south those are just too
good dads right there I thought I had to
leave that child as soon as I graduated
high school and I mean that like I threw
the hat up I was like 45 minutes outside
of town before it even landed can I go
back to see my family sometimes last
time I went home I rented some old
friends and Friends that left like I did
and some friends that never left you
tell who they are right away cuz they've
gained like 1500 pounds and kids have
already dropped out of high school I'm
35 dude that math real quick thank you
[Laughter]
send me all clapping didn't even do the
math so just calm down
we were all hanging out catching up in
the middle of conversation with my
friends had never left lift up see with
my friends that had left walking up and
he'd lost his mind he's at 30 I had seen
that dude right turn the goons age like
nope shut your mouth stop stop saying
racist stuff with your mouth right now
stop without missing a beat just
scratching his belly like think that's
racist I've been saying that for years
that doesn't help your argument at all
he's like google it and he pulled out an
iPhone cuz evidently anybody can get one
and he talked in Coons age and it turns
out he's correct coincidentally he was
correct
the term Coons age comes from the 1800s
when people thought that raccoons lived
forever
they thought raccoons were immortal
that's amazing to me the origin of Coons
ages dumber than racism not many things
dumber than race isn't he guys I could
only they could do things repealing poor
people's health it care
you should probably applaud that yes and
ventriloquism that needs to stop tonight
you who likes ventriloquism children
about eight years old because their
brain still forming they don't know any
better and old people about setting me
above because their brains just falling
out every poor and I'll do it hurts
every day it does I wake up every day it
hurts
look at that it's amazing he's barely
moving his mouth he's not racist the
puppeteers
thank you okay I guess I guess about me
wrote the jokes you guys are fantastic
I'm Billy right - thank you for having
me
you